مع رحلات مباشرة من أكثر من 95
وجهة دولية ، تطير
الخطوط الجوية الإثيوبية الروح الجديدة لأفريقيا ،
الخطوط الجوية الإثيوبية المملوكة للدولة العضو في التحالف النجمي هي
الناقل الأول في إفريقيا
لحركة الركاب والشحن ،
ولكن من بين أدلة الشحن المنتظمة على
الشحنات الشريرة التي
يمكن أن تكشفها CNN بناءً على
أدلة وثائقية  وشهادات الشهود
قامت الخطوط الجوية الإثيوبية بنقل
الأسلحة بين إثيوبيا وإريتريا
منذ بداية الحرب في
إثيوبيا التي شهدت مقتل الآلاف
وفقًا لخبراء الطيران ، وهذا من شأنه أن
يشكل انتهاكًا لقانون الطيران من
بين الأدلة ، هذه اللقطات التي
تم التقاطها على متن الطائرة الإثيوبية
رحلة الخطوط الجوية رقم
et3313 والتحقق منها بواسطة CNN
[موسيقى]
إنه منتصف الليل
يتم تحميل طائرة الشحن هذه يدويًا بطريقة بطيئة وغير
تقليدية ولكن انظر عن كثب ، فهذه
ليست البضائع المعتادة داخل هذه الصناديق عبارة عن
قذائف
هاون يتم تحميلها على هذا المدني
الطائرات المنقولة من إريتريا إلى
إثيوبيا
هنا ط  في بيان الشحن الذي
يؤكد اليوم والوقت في الثامن من تشرين الثاني (نوفمبر) 2020 ،
فإن التاريخ مهم ، إنه مجرد أربعة
أيام من الصراع وقبل أشهر من
اعتراف إريتريا رسميًا بالتورط
، كانت إثيوبيا في حالة حرب مع
حكومة تيغراي الإقليمية ، وجبهة تحرير شعب تيغراي
لما يقرب من
أصبحت إريتريا في الشمال
حليفًا للحكومة الإثيوبية ضد
منطقة تيغري ،
وهو تحالف غير عادي حيث كانت الدول
في السابق في حالة حرب مع بعضها البعض
الآن لديهم عدو مشترك إلى اللون الرمادي
وهم يتشاركون الأسلحة.
كان يكتب عن الفظائع في
إثيوبيا منذ بداية العام
إذا كنت تريد أن تحتجز فريق سي
إن إن ، فهذا ما حدث الآن
لأننا لن نذهب إلى المخيم عن طيب خاطر ،
سافرنا إلى تيغراي في أبريل الماضي
ورأينا بأنفسنا قوات إريتريا.
نقاط التفتيش مع الإفلات من العقاب بينما
نفت الحكومة الإثيوبية
وجودها على الأرض
تلك العلاقة بين e
بدأت إثيوبيا وإريتريا قبل أشهر في نوفمبر
2020 والتي تزامنت مع زيادة
في حركة الأسلحة التي يتم نقلها
ذهابًا وإيابًا من العاصمة الإثيوبية إلى
إريتريا
خلال نفس الشهر ، كما كانت هناك
سلسلة من المذابح في منطقة
تيغري التي
تحولت إلى موظف في الخطوط الجوية الإثيوبية.
تحدث المُبلغ عن المخالفات إلى CNN حول
كيفية تعامله مع طلب غير معتاد
[موسيقى]
في بيانات مختلفة
، لطالما أنكرت الخطوط الجوية الإثيوبية بشدة نقل
أسلحة على متن طائرات ركاب أو شحن ،
ولكن بالإضافة إلى التحدث مع
المبلغين عن المخالفات للتحقق من بيانات الشحن
وتوثيق اللقطات التي
حصلت عليها CNN  إيصالات الفواتير التي تظهر
على الأقل ست مناسبات في نوفمبر حيث
تبني الخطوط الجوية الإثيوبية
وزارة الدفاع الإثيوبية لشحن
المواد العسكرية بما في ذلك البنادق والذخيرة إلى
إريتريا
في النهاية ، يعد نجاح
شركات الطيران الإثيوبية رمزًا مهمًا ومثيرًا للإعجاب
للإمكانات اللامحدودة للولايات
المتحدة  الشراكة
الاثيوبية الخطوط الجوية الاثيوبية ب  تبنى هيمنتها على الشحنات ،
فإن العلاقة مع
الحكومة الأمريكية وعملاق الطيران الأمريكي
بوينج
هذه النتائج الجديدة التي توصلت إليها CNN بالإضافة
إلى التحقيقات السابقة في الفظائع التي
ارتكبتها القوات الإثيوبية
ستشكل انتهاكات للقانون الدولي
وفقًا لخبراء الطيران
وتتعارض مع شروط تلك
العلاقة مع  الحكومة الأمريكية
ما إذا كان هذا يجبرنا على العمل
بشكل جوهري ضد الحكومة الإثيوبية
لم يتضح بعد